I've written down the identities here
for us and you can see that sine of PI
over 2 which is like 90 degrees this is
in radians but PI over 2 is 90 so cosine
cosine of 90 minus theta equals sine of
theta and sine of 90 minus theta equals
cosine theta so if you can remember that
sine and cosine are Co functions secant
and cosecant tangent and cotangent
that's an easy way to remember them but
let's look at the triangle here a right
triangle and kind of analyze you know
why it works and you know where these
come from so for example if you're here
at this angle theta and this is a 90
degree angle this angle over here has to
be 90 minus theta because all angles in
a triangle have to add up to 180 degrees
if this one's 90 these two have to add
up to 90 so say for example if this was
10 this would have to be 80 degrees
because he's add up to a total of 90
degrees right so let's just say we're
here at this angle we want to find the
sine of theta sine is opposite over
hypotenuse that's 4/5 right so let's
write that down but if you want to do
cosine of 90 minus theta that's adjacent
over hypotenuse that's also 4/5 so see
how they're equivalent so it depends on
what angle you're working with so let's
take this next one say you wanted to
find a secant of this angle okay secant
is hypotenuse over adjacent so that's
5/3 right so let me write that that down
for us but the cosecant of 90 minus
theta is hypotenuse over opposite that's
also 5/3 and same thing for tangent like
tangent is opposite over adjacent that's
4/3 but if we do the cotangent of 90
minus theta that's adjacent arap so
that's also 4/3 so depending on what
angle you're using if you use the
complementary angle or the cofunction
okay you know you're gonna get an
equivalent value so let's look at some
examples I'll show you how it works so
say for example you wanted to simplify
this expression well tangent of PI over
2 minus theta we know that's equal to
cotangent of theta right and cosine of
theta we can leave that as cosine of
theta now you probably remember from
earlier that cotangent of theta is
cosine of theta divided by the sine of
theta all divided by this cosine of
theta here anything divided by 1 is
itself so I can write that over 1 now
when you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal right so
this is like multiplying by 1 over
cosine theta
and you can see the cosine Thetas cancel
numerator and denominator and you're
left with one over sine well what does 1
over sine theta equal well that equals
cosecant theta and we've simplified it
down so using Co functions right okay
let's look at another example say for
example you had sine squared of 10
degrees plus sine squared of let's just
say it was let's just say what could we
do here let's say maybe 70 degrees 80
degrees right so what you notice here is
that these two angles they add up to 90
degrees right they're complementary but
what we can do is we could say well hmm
using our Col functions I know that sine
squared of 80 degrees is actually the
same thing as cosine squared of 90 minus
80 degrees which is 10 degrees okay
so I'm just going to bring down this
sine squared of 10 degrees plus cosine
squared of 10 degrees and you've
probably learned from earlier in the
chapter or earlier in the year that sine
squared plus cosine squared equals 1 so
this whole thing condenses down to 1
this is just the Pythagorean trig
identity as long as these angles are the
same sine squared plus cosine squared is
equal to 1 so this is a brief overview
here of how to understand you know
working with Co functions if you're
enjoying these math videos consider
supporting me on patreon I'll have a
link for that and subscribe to the
channel check out more math videos on
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon